Her hair is curly hair day
Everyone on the island made fun of me
But I told her I liked her hair Because she was the
only one who would call my name when I started
Bad boy Kobara, he's also curry, damn kid, that's
what all the people on the island call
me.My first son and
my father were hated on the island and had various bad rumors.As
soon as I joined Shibata's 2nd division  The Qing War has begun There
is no place for me on this island After I
finish cleaning, I will change it for you
I will elope at that time
I had a very bad feeling.When I returned
to Sado,
the people on the island looked at me like
a ghost.I heard that you were killed in
action.  It seems that the
autumn guardian was found on the beach
[Music]
I searched desperately every day
, wondering if she was caught in the corner of the rock
[Music]
Every time I saw her move as it washed up on the beach, by any
chance.  When
I came to
my senses, where did the theme that I was killed in action come from
[Music]
Annin was my father?
[MUSIC]
How far should I drag my life down
Before I knew it my father
was snoring in a pool of blood
[MUSIC]